La península de los Balcanes es un lugar
con 12 países que tienen una única cosa
en común: el odio que se
tienen unos a otros.
Durante décadas, la mayor parte de estos
países estaban unidos en una gran
Federación, lo que por entonces se llamaba
Yugoslavia,
que tenía un sistema socialista,
muy parecido al
de la Unión Soviética.
Pero tras la caída del comunismo, el Estado
Yugoslavo se vino abajo y todas las
regiones que lo conformaban se separaron de
la forma más violenta que os podéis imaginar.
Los que tengáis
más de 30 años recordaréis las terribles
guerras de los Balcanes.
Todo un escaparate de lo más oscuro de
la condición humana.
Y todo eso a pocos kilómetros de distancia
de Italia o Grecia.
Mientras en el resto de Europa vivíamos con
relativa comodidad, en esta región se estaban
matando de las
peores formas posibles.
Desde entonces, los Balcanes son una de las
zonas más pobres de Europa.
Algunos lo llaman el TRIÁNGULO DE
LAS BERMUDAS ECONÓMICO porque cuando alguien
invierte en esta región, su dinero desaparece
misteriosamente.
Viajar a un país como Albania es como viajar
50 años atrás en el tiempo.
Otros países como Serbia están
creciendo mucho en los últimos años, pero
todavía están a años luz de poder entrar
en la Unión Europea.
Y Grecia, que sería algo así como el alumno
aventajado de la clase, está en bancarrota
y con un desempleo
del 21%.
Vamos, que no parece precisamente, el mejor
lugar para hacer negocios ¿Verdad?
Pues, mis queridos amigos
de VisualPolitik, China no piensa como vosotros.
China está poniendo miles de millones de
euros en inversiones tanto en Grecia como
en otros países
balcánicos para crear una “Nueva ruta de
la sede” que va desde el Mediterráneo hasta
el corazón de la
Unión Europea.
Hablamos de casi 20.000 millones de dólares,
es decir, el coste de unos Juegos Olímpicos,
en una región
donde prácticamente nadie más invierte.
China ha comprado un puerto y está levando
nuevas líneas de
ferrocarril que conectarán los Balcanes con
Budapest y que podrían terminar llegando
hasta Alemania
¡Pero no sólo eso!
El gobierno chino está allanando el camino
para que puedan llegar inversores privados
¿Os imagináis fábricas chinas en las afueras
de Belgrado?
¿Centros logísticos de Aliexpres en Atenas¿
Pues es muy probablemente que eso sea una realidad
mucho antes de lo que nos pensemos.
Para que os hagáis si lo miramos en términos
relativos a la población, China está mostrando
mucho más
interés en Grecia o Serbia que en la mismísima
Alemania.
Y os preguntaréis ¿A qué se debe todo este
interés en los Balcanes?
¿No sé supone que es una zona pobre,
corrupta y con condiciones pésimas para la
inversión?
¿Qué quiere conseguir China en los Balcanes?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero antes…
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
UN PAÍS DE SALDO
En el año 2010, Grecia comienza con sus programas
de ajuste de presupuesto.
El país entero estaba en
bancarrota y la Unión Europea aceptó rescatarlo
con el dinero de los países más ricos de
Europa a cambio
de que el Gobierno se apretara el cinturón.
Desde entonces, Grecia ha estado inmersa en
toda clase de
crisis políticas y económicas.
El desempleo se ha situado por encima del
20% y la pobreza no ha dejado de
crecer.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Grecia tiene
una deuda que es casi 2 veces su PIB
A eso hay que sumarle que, tradicionamente,
ha sido un país alérgico a los negocios.
Corrupción,
Burocracia y toda clase de restricciones que
hacen que apenas haya empresas importantes
en este país.
Desde Bruselas exigían que el Gobierno de
Tsipras hiciera reformas políticas y vendiera
alguna de las
empresas públicas para hacer frente a la
enorme deuda que tienen ¿El problema?
Que con semejante
panorama, las propiedades del Gobierno Griego
se tuvieron que sacar a precio de saldo.
De otro modo,
nadie estaría dispuesto a comprar.
En otras palabras, que Grecia estaba (y todavía
está) en una situación
desesperada.
Y si hay alguien que puede oler la desesperación,
esa es China.
La empresa china COSCO adquiera el 51% de
la propiedad del Puerto Griego del Pireo
Con esta operación, China mataba dos pájaros
de un tiro.
Por un lado, una de sus empresas se hacía
con
uno de los principales puertos del Mediterráneo.
Por el otro, el gobierno de Xi Jimping se
comprometía a
invertir otros 3.000 millones de dólares
en el país para ganarse a todo un aliado
político en la Unión Europea.
Que sí, que ya sé lo que estáis pensando.
El presidente de Grecia, Alexis Tsipras, es
toda una
rock star de la izquierda europea ¿Verdad?
Un hombre que jamás vendería sus ideas a
un malvado
capitalista por mucho dinero que ponga en
la mesa ¿Verdad?
Pues… lo cierto es que no.
Grecia bloquea las críticas de la Unión
Europea a las violaciones de Derechos Humanos
de China
Grecia ha vetado una condena de la Unión
Europea en la ONU, enfureciendo a los diplomáticos
y las
organizaciones humanitarias que dicen que
este movimiento socava la posición de la
UE al defender los
Derechos Humanos.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
de política vive el hombre!
Vamos a mirarlo desde el punto de
vista económico.
Ahora las empresas chinas controlan uno de
los puertos más grandes de Europa.
Eso
significa que las empresas chinas tienen más
facilidad que nunca para descargar containers
con sus
mercancías en uno de los mercados más ricos
del planeta: Europa.
Pero hay un pequeño problema.
Desde el puerto
del Pireo hasta Berlín hay más de 2300 kilómetros.
Y por el camino sólo atravesamos países
relativamente
pobres, con malas carreteras y ferrocarriles
cochambrosos ¡Pero tranquilos porque China
también ha
pensado en eso!
¿Os acordáis de este vídeo en el que os
hablábamos de la nueva ruta de la seda, el
llamado proyecto One Belt, one Road que quiere
construir Xi Jimping?
Se trata de una red de
infraestructuras que conectarían el mundo
entero.
Y en Europa, esta ruta de la seda pasa, directamente,
por los Balcanes.
Comienza la construcción del ferrocarril
Belgrado-Budapest
A la vez, varias consultoras chinas están trabajando
para renovar las rutas de ferrocarril de Grecia
entre Grecia y Macedonia.
La idea es que, en un futuro, un cargamento
que desembarque en el Pireo puede atravesar
toda la península balcánica a una velocidad de
160 kilómetros por hora.
Y todo por un precio mucho más barato
que si las mismas líneas de ferrocarril se
construyeran en, vamos a decir, Italia.
Pensadlo bien, en los
Balcanes el terreno y la mano de obra es más
barata que en ninguna parte de Europa.
Y los gobiernos están
recibiendo la inversión con los brazos abiertos.
Como decíamos al principio, los Balcanes
todavía no se han terminado de recuperar
tras las guerras de los
años 90.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en una ciudad
como Belgrado todavía se pueden ver edificios
derruidos por los bombardeos de la OTAN del
año 1999.
Y un país como Montenegro ni siquiera tiene
ferrocarril que le conecte con Bosnia o Croacia,
y todo esto a pesar de que son países vecinos.
Y no olvidéis que, salvo Grecia y Croacia, ninguno
de estos estados pertenece a la Unión Europea.
Eso significa que apenas reciben dinero de Bruselas
para reconstruirse.
Así que los préstamos que está
haciendo China vienen como maná caído del
cielo.
“Cuando hablamos de esto con los países
Europeos, nos preguntan ¿Por qué China?
¡Pues para ser honestos,
porque son los que tienen el dinero!
¡Pero esperad un momento porque aquí no
termina la historia!
¿Y si China estuviera dispuesta a ir aún
más lejos?
¿FACTORÍAS CHINAS EN EUROPA?
Todos lo sabemos, China comenzó a crecer
gracias a las empresas extranjeras que se
instalaban en las
zonas económicas especiales.
Por cierto que si queréis conocer esta historia
más a fondo, la explicamos
en este otro vídeo.
Pero lo cierto es que el principal atractivo
que ofrecía China en los años 90 eran,
seamos honestos, los salarios bajos.
Sin embargo, las cosas ya no son lo que eran.
Fijaos en la gráfica…
Hoy en día, el sueldo medio en una ciudad
como Shanghai es casi el mismo que el que
se cobra en Grecia.
Y más del doble que lo que se cobra en Serbia.
Es decir, que para una empresa china, Belgrado
sería algo
parecido a lo que en su día podía ser Shenzhen
para un estadounidense.
A eso hay que sumarle que la
educación en un país como Serbia es razonablemente
buena y que está tiro de piedra de Alemania.
En otras palabras, tenemos mano de obra barata, bien
educada y cercana a uno de los mercados más
atractivos del planeta
Vamos, que es el paraíso para poder hacer
cosas como esta.
La empresa china HEBEI firma un acuerdo para
comprar una planta de acero Serbia.
Por supuesto que la noticia es del año 2016
y todavía no hay muchos más ejemplos para mostrar.
Pero son  casos son suficientes como para percibir una
tendencia.
Las empresas chinas quieren empezar a fabricar
cosas en Europa y los Balcanes son la zona
perfecta.
Más concretamente Serbia.
Y eso explica que ese
mismo año, el mismísimo Xi Jimping hiciera
una visita oficial a Belgrado.
O que Huawei haya invertido una
barbaridad en mejorar las telecomunicaciones
del país.
El año pasado, en 2017, el Banco de China
abrió
sus primeras sucursales Serbias.
Vamos, que las relaciones entre estos dos
países no podían ser mejores.
¡Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Siempre os decimos aquí, en VisualPolitik,
que la corrupción no se
lleva muy bien con la inversión extranjera.
Y en lo que a corrupción se refiere, Serbia
no parece el
lugar más transparente del planeta.
Pero si por algo se caracterizan los empresarios
chinos es por moverse como pez en el agua
en los
entornos más hostiles.
Ya lo han demostrado con todas las fábricas
textiles que han montado en países
como Etiopía.
Y, seamos honestos, su propio país, China,
tampoco es un oasis de seguridad jurídica
y democracia, que digamos.
Mientras tanto, a medida que la inversión
llega a los Balcanes, el europeísmo en esta
zona está en horas
bajas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2012,
el 70% de los serbios quería entrar en la
Unión Europea
Incluso algunos se plantaban cambiar el alfabeto.
Por si no lo sabíais, el serbio es una lengua
eslava y se escribe en alfabeto cirílico.
Pues bien, muchos intelectuales proponían
cambiarse al alfabeto
latino, como ya se hizo, por ejemplo, en Croacia.
Pues bien, ese fervor europeísta ha bajado
al 35%.
A fin de cuentas… teniendo el dinero chino
¿Quién necesita los fondos de cohesión
de Bruselas?
En las pasadas elecciones presidenciales,
ninguno de los principales candidatos a Presidente
del país
hablaba de entrar en la Unión Europea.
Sin embargo, no parece que nada de esto preocupe
demasiado en Bruselas.
Como os decía, hasta el momento,
solamente China ha sido capaz de ver oportunidades
de negocio en esta zona del mundo.
Para el resto de
los mortales, los Balcanes son un desierto
tanto político como económico.
Algo parecido ocurrió con
muchas zonas de África, donde nadie se atrevía
a invertir.
De repente llegó el dinero de Pekín y hoy
en
día están creciendo como si no existiera
mañana.
Así que la pregunta es… ¿Veremos un despertar
en los Balcanes, tal y como está ocurriendo
en otras zonas
de África?
¿Podría convertirse Grecia, o Serbia, o
Bosnia Herzegovina, en un nuevo centro industrial
para
los mercados europeos?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis saber más sobre
las inversiones brutales que China está acometiendo
en África,
haced click en este otro vídeo.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.